-Welcome back, everybody.
We are hanging out
with Keegan-Michael Key!
-Hey!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now, Keegan, when you're --
when you're acting,
is there anything you do
to get ready for a scene?
Do you do vocal warm-ups
or anything like that?
-I do.
I do do vocal warm-ups.
I do -- Like, sometimes I'll do
just voice warm-ups,
but other times
I'll do tongue twisters
if I know that I'm doing a role
that's got more dialogue in it
and stuff like that.
-That's perfect.
We thought we could
put your skills to the test
in a game we call
"Fast Talkers."
-♪ Fast talkers,
talking so fast ♪
♪ Fast talkers, ooh ♪
-All right.
Now, here's how it works.
We're gonna draw a card
from our pile.
Each one has
a tongue twister on it.
We'll have to say
the tongue twister
as many times
as we can in 10 seconds.
Whoever can say
it most times wins.
-Ah! Okay.
Whoever can say it the most.
-All right.
So this is the first one here.
Round one, I will go first.
-Okay. All right.
-All right.
You got that one, too?
-I got the same one.
-It says, "Crunch wrap supreme
is a dream for the spleen."
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
-All right.
So I'll just look in this.
10 seconds on the clock.
Okay. Wah, wah, wah.
-Wah, wah, wah.
-Many mumbling mice are making
midnight music in the moonlight.
-Guac is extra.
Wow, wow, guac.
[ Laughter ]
Wow.
Look at all this guac.
-There's a lot of guac.
-Wow, wow.
All right, here we go.
Ready?
Crunch wrap supreme
is a dream for the spleen.
Crunch wrap supreme is
a dream for the spleen.
Crunch wrap supreme
is a dream for the spleen.
Crunch wrap supreme is
a dream for the spleen.
Crunch wrap supreme
is a dream for the spleen.
Crunch wrap supreme is
a dream for the spleen.
Crunch wrap supreme
is a dream for the spleen.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Wow.
-Whoo!
-Wow.
-Wow! Wow!
-Wow!
-Wow.
-[ Laughs ]
-Wo-- [ Laughs ]
-Gwow!
-I mean, gwow.
How many did I get there?
Ooh, I got seven.
Lucky seven.
Seven, okay, all right.
-Wo you got to beat seven.
-Okay, let's see if I can do --
I can beat seven.
Okay. Tell me when
the clock is going here.
-Whenever you start
is when we start.
-Okay. Here we go.
Crunch wrap supreme
is a dream for the spleen.
Crunch wrap supreme is a dream
for the spleen.
Crunch wrap supreme
is a dream for the spleen.
Crunch wrap supreme is a dream
for the spleen.
Crunch wrap supreme
is a dream for the spleen.
Crunch wrap supreme is a dream
for the spleen.
Crunch wrap supreme
is a dream for the spleen.
Crunch wrap supreme is a dream
for the spleen.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Judges?
-Wow.
-How man--
Eight!
-Whoo!
Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Holy mackerel.
-[ Laughs ]
-Whoo!
-That was...
-Crunch wrap supreme.
-Gwow!
-Oh, that's like wow.
-Gwow. It is a tight one.
-Wow!
-That was a tight one.
I'm only up by one, folks.
-Only up by one.
-Holy MacGrubers.
-Okay.
We got a second one here.
The second one here says...
Schmigadoon features tunes
you can croon to the schmoon.
-To the schmoon.
Oh, my gosh.
That's -- That's -- That's.
That's challenging.
That's the word
that's gonna get us.
-I guess I'll go first
on this one. Ready?
-You got it. All right.
-Schmigadoon features tunes
you can croon to the schmoon.
Schmigadoon features tunes you
can croon to the schmoon.
Schmigadoon features tunes
you can croon to the schmoon.
Schmigadoon features tunes you
can croon to the schmoon.
Schmigadoon features tunes --
[ Buzzer ]
Come on.
I don't like it.
I hate this game.
I don't like this game --
[ Both laugh ]
Oh, my God.
Oh, my heavens.
[ Laughter ]
How many did I get?
Did I get any?
Four.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, my God.
[ Both laugh ]
-"Shoo-her-me-her-her."
[ Laughter ]
You sounded like you were
from Sweden.
-"Schern her-der-schern."
-"Schoon de-her-de foon-dun."
[ Both speaking
Swedish-sounding gibberish ]
[ Both laugh ]
All right.
-Your turn.
-Okay. Here we go.
Mwah, mwah, mwah, guac.
Okay, here we go.
[ Laughter ]
Schmigadoon features tunes
you can croon to the schmoon.
Schmigadoon features tunes you
can croon to the schmoon.
Schmigadoon features tunes
you can croon to the schmoon.
Shugga-shoon --
Schmigadoon features tunes
you can croon to the schmoon.
Schmigadoon features tunes you
can croon to the schmoon.
[ Buzzer ]
Oh!
Did I get it at the end there?
-Totally, dude.
[ Repeating gibberish ]
How many do we got?
Judges?
Five!
-Five! Oh, my God!
Nail biter!
Oh, my goodness.
This thing is a nail...
-I say whaaa?
-Whaaa?
[ Laughter ]
-All right. It is up
for the final round.
Whoever wins this round,
I just heard from the judges,
wins the whole game.
-Oh, oh, you just heard
from the judges?
-Yeah, I just heard
the same thing from the judges.
I just heard the same --
-The same thing.
They said the same thing to you?
-Yeah, yeah.
Hold up. Yeah.
-Yeah. I'm sorry.
This judge is saying something
different than this judge.
[ Laughter ]
Sorry.
-Different.
Different judges over here.
-This judge here says no.
-Okay.
-This judge says --
-This guy's giving me --
This is a 9.5 for you.
And the East German
judge gives me a 9.5.
-All right. This -- this judge
says to say hello.
-This judge --
This judge is saying goodbye.
-Okay. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
This judge is -- yeah.
All right, here we go.
Last one.
The tongue twister is...
Super Mario is rated PG
with Peach and Toad
and Mario and Luigi.
Wait. What?
Oh.
Super Mario is rated PG
with Peach and Toad
and Mario and Luigi.
-[ Whistles ]
-Super Mario is ra--
Okay, yeah, I got it.
-Okay. All right.
You got --
You got this, man.
Here it comes. You're gonna --
Here comes the redemption.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Scoffs ]
-I don't need a redem--
I don't need a redemption.
I said I did --
-What am I talking about?
-What am I doing?
What am I doing?
What am I talking about?
All right, here we go.
-[ Laughs ]
Super Mario is rated PG
with Peach and Toad
and Mario and Luigi.
Super Mario is rated PG
with Peach and Toad
and Mario and Luigi.
Super Mario is rated PG
with Peach and Toad
and Mario and Luigi.
Super Mario is rated PG
with Peach and Toad
and Mario and Luigi.
Super Mario is rated PG
with Peach and Toad
and Mario and Luigi.
Super Mario is rated PG --
[ Buzzer ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause
continues ]
♪♪
-Wow.
[ Cheers and applause
continues ]
Wow.
-Wow.
-Holy mackerel.
[ Laughter ]
-I -- I -- I -- I don't even --
I don't know what to say.
[ Laughter ]
If you can believe it,
I'm tongue-tied.
-Oh!
Judges, how many --
No, no, no!
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Are you clapping, too?
[ Laughs ]
And the clapping, too?
-And the clapping.
-All right.
-I haven't even done anything.
-Yeah, no, exactly.
-I'm just -- I'm just
tiring myself out for no reason.
-Okay.
-Here we --
[ Laughs ]
How many did he get?
-I got six.
-Six?
-Yes, you have to beat six.
-Wow. Okay.
All right, here we go.
[ Drumroll ]
[ Clears throat ]
Super Mario is rated PG
with Peach and Toad
and Mario and Luigi.
Super Mario is rated PG
with Peach and Toad
and Mario and Luigi.
Super Mario is rated PG
with Peach and Toad
and Mario and Luigi.
Super Mario is rated PG
with Peach and Toad
and Mario and Luigi.
Super Mario is rated PG
with Peach and Toad --
[ Buzzer ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-No, no.
No, no, no, no!
[ Both laugh ]
Come on!
That's Keegan-Michael Key
right there. Come on.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Tomorrow is Keegan-Michael Key
Day in America.
"Schmigadoon!" is out.
The "Super Mario Bros. Movie"
are both out tomorrow!
We'll be right back
with more "Tonight Show,"
everybody.